Die Seychellen:
ein Naturparadies im Indischen Ozean.
Es ist der Arbeitsort
von Ornella Weideli und ihrem Team.
Die Biologin
erforscht hier zwei Junghai-Arten.
Geh zu Ryan! Dann bewegen wir uns
entlang der Sandbank.
Im Saint-Joseph-Atoll
wimmelt es von Junghaien,
denn hier sind sie sicher
vor ihren Feinden.
Das Team fängt sie
mit einem Netz ein.
Normalerweise benutzt man die Netze:
Man legt sie aus und wartet,
manchmal kreist man sie ein.
Im Moment sehen wir
gerade mehrere dort hinten.
Es ist sehr einfach,
Zitronenhaie zu erkennen.
Die beiden Rückenflossen
haben beide dieselbe Grösse.
Wenn zwei so rausstehen,
so gelblich, bräunlich,
ist es immer ein Zitronenhai.
Beim Schwarzspitzenriffhai sieht man
immer nur die erste Rückenflosse.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir sind im Indischen Ozean,
auf den Seychellen.
Ornella Weideli
forscht auf der Insel D'Arros
und im nahe gelegenen
Saint-Joseph-Atoll.
Hier am Äquator ist die
Sonneneinstrahlung sehr stark.
Zum Schutz
tragen alle Kopfbedeckung und Tücher.
Ornella arbeitet
für die Stiftung Save Our Seas,
Ryan Daly ist deren lokaler
wissenschaftlicher Direktor.
Wurde der schon mal gefangen?
Er ist neu. Ein Zitronenhai,
ein kleines Männchen.
Ein Männchen.
So N for Nadja.
Der junge Zitronenhai
wird mit einem Chip versehen,
so erkennt ihn das Team
später wieder.
Dann kontrollieren wir
die Chipnummer:
2-1-7-6-9.
- 2-1-7-6-9.
Das Hauptziel ist,
besser zu verstehen,
was die Tiere essen,
wie es ihnen geht,
wie viel sie wachsen, wie weit sie
in den ersten Jahren gehen.
Einige Haie sahen wir
während drei Jahren immer hier.
Wir haben sie dann dort hinten
und hier wiedergefunden.
Sie gehen zwischen 500
und 1'000 m, also 1 km weiter.
Und solche Daten sind natürlich
sehr wichtig für den Schutz.
Wenn man weiss, die Haie bleiben da,
und man das Atoll schützen kann,
dann ist die ganze Jungzeit ge-
schützt. Das ist natürlich perfekt.
Ausgewachsene Zitronenhaie
können über 3 m lang
und bis zu 30 Jahre alt werden.
Okay, 49.3, 55.1, 63.1.
Jetzt nehmen wir
noch eine DNA-Probe.
Dem Jungtier wird ein winziger Teil
der Rückenflosse abgeschnitten.
Anhand der DNA kann später der Ver-
wandtschaftsgrad zwischen den Tieren
rekonstruiert werden.
Hier habe ich das Privileg, dass ich
etwas von Grund auf aufbauen konnte.
Diese Haie hier
hat niemand vorher gefangen.
Und als Biologin
macht das natürlich sehr viel Spass,
wenn man einfach hingehen
und schauen kann, was da ist.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir hier arbeiten,
sind es das Meer und die Haie.
Das ist ein unglaubliches Gefühl.
Es wird leider immer seltener,
dass man an Orten arbeiten kann,
wo man
nicht mit Menschen in Kontakt ist.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Fröhliches indonesisches Lied *
Seit drei Jahren ist das indonesische
Tauchparadies Raja Ampat
für den Schweizer Jonas Müller
Heimat und Herzensangelegenheit.
Okay, jetzt haben wir
hier ein tolles Buch,
in dem es um den Plastikabfall
in Raja Ampat geht.
Dieses Buch ist extra
für Raja Ampat gemacht.
Man sieht auf den Bildern gut,
dass es wirklich so aussieht
in Raja Ampat.
D.h., die Kinder haben einen
sehr hohen Wiedererkennungswert.
Man sieht z.B. hier mit den Mantas,
was ja auch
sehr für Raja Ampat spricht.
Und das Buch erzählt die Geschichte
zweier Kinder, die lernen,
dass Plastik ein Abfallproblem ist.
Sein Lernzentrum betreibt Jonas
Müller in Indonesien in Südostasien.
Bei West-Papua
liegt das Tauchparadies Raja Ampat.
Der 28-jährige Glarner will,
dass die Kinder hier
die ökologischen Zusammenhänge
kennenlernen.
Das geht nur mit Konzentration.
(Indonesisch) Hört zu,
ihr müsst euch jetzt konzentrieren,
wenn jemand eine Geschichte erzählt.
Nicht einfach dasitzen,
den Wind geniessen und relaxen.
Verstanden?
(Alle) Ja.
- Dann bildet jetzt Gruppen, bitte.
Jonas führt ein einfaches Leben
zusammen mit den Einheimischen.
Dafür gab er seine Karriere auf,
kam hierher und lernte Indonesisch.
Ich möchte, dass sie lernen,
dass es sich lohnt,
sich für die wunderschöne Natur
einzusetzen.
Denn man wird es von der Natur
wieder zurückbekommen.
Und sie sind von der Natur so
abhängig wie wenige andere Menschen.
Wovon handelt diese Geschichte?
Vom Abfall.
Wenn jemand etwas sagen will,
streckt bitte auf
und ich wähle jemanden aus.
Abraham, was meinst du?
* Lachen *
Ihr sollt nicht lachen.
Warum will er das essen?
Wer hat das im Buch gesehen?
- (Alle) Novi.
Er hat Angst,
dass die Schildkröte was macht?
(Alle) Es isst.
Was will sie essen?
- (Alle) Plastik.
Es wurde in den letzten zwei, drei
Jahren zu einem sehr grossen Thema.
Es hat einerseits mit dem
aufkommenden Tourismus zu tun,
aber es ist leider weltweit ein
grosses Problem, v.a. in Indonesien.
Und das Verständnis bei den lokalen
Menschen ist noch gar nicht da.
Als ich angefangen habe,
war für sie ein Stöckchen
oder eine Plastikflasche am Strand
genau dasselbe.
Das ist das Verständnis. Es geht
darum, Verständnis aufzubauen,
weshalb es für sie ein Problem ist
und was sie dagegen tun können.
Ich versuche,
sie dabei zu unterstützen.
Wer ist in Gruppe 2?
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Du bist in Gruppe 3.
* Entspannte Musik *
Auf den Seychellen erforscht
die Bernerin Ornella Weideli
junge Zitronenhaie
und Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
An einigen Orten der Welt
sind diese gefährdet.
Doch hier
bietet ihnen das Atoll Schutz.
Und sie kommen zahlreich vor.
1 kg.
- 1 kg.
Ein bissiger!
Weder die kleinen
noch die grossen Zitronenhaie
lassen nach dem Zubeissen
wieder los.
Deshalb ist es ziemlich gefährlich,
von ihnen gebissen zu werden.
Die meisten Leute ziehen
aus Reflex die Hand weg.
Besser ist, den Finger drin zu
lassen, wenn nur der drin ist.
Irgendwann lassen sie los.
Nachdem Ornella und ihr Team die
Tiere vermessen und gechippt haben,
entlassen sie
sie wieder in die Freiheit.
Jetzt haben wir wieder einen.
Schwarzspitzen-Riffhai? Okay.
Wieder ein Schwarzspitzen-Riff-
und ein Zitronenhai.
Zitronenhaie können
in ihren eigenen Schwanz beissen.
Sie sind sehr flexibel. Deshalb muss
man mit den Fingern sehr aufpassen.
Es blutet extrem, wenn sie
einen in den Finger beissen.
Das ist jetzt ein Weibchen.
Hast du gesehen,
wie er zugeschnappt hat?
7-7-2, den hatten wir schon mal.
Das ist einer, den wir
schon mal gefangen haben.
Als Ryan ihn rausnahm,
sah er bereits,
dass hier ein kleiner Teil
der Flosse fehlt.
Normalerweise
ist sie so spitzig wie hier,
aber ein kleiner Teil fehlt.
Wir wissen also, dass wir
ihn schon mal gefangen haben.
Wir wissen aber noch nicht,
ob das 2015, 2016 oder 2014 war.
Das können wir
in der Database nachschauen.
Wir machen jetzt genau dasselbe:
Wir messen sie aus und wiegen sie.
Wir haben GPS
und können entsprechend schauen:
"Letztes Mal war er auch genau hier,
er ist soundso viel gewachsen."
Das bringt uns extrem gute Angaben
dazu, wie es den Tieren geht.
Die Rückenflosse
des Schwarzspitzen-Riffhais
ist
wie ein individueller Fingerabdruck.
An ihr und den Daten im Chip können
die Forscher das Tier wiedererkennen.
Du kannst hier eine Zwei schreiben.
51.6 und 61.6.
Wir lassen ihn frei.
Es ist schon 17.50 Uhr.
Es ist Zeit zu gehen. Die Sonne
scheint noch hoch zu stehen.
In der Schweiz würde es noch ca.
3 Std. dauern, bis es dunkel ist.
Hier dauert es noch ca. 50 Min.,
dann ist es bereits dunkel.
Da wir am Äquator sind,
gehen Sonnenauf- und Sonnenuntergang
sehr schnell.
Okay, shall we get the net?
* Ruhige Musik *
Wir haben vier Haie gefangen. Per-
fekt! Ich kann mich nicht beklagen.
Einen Zitronenhai
und drei Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
Einen hatten wir schon mal gefangen.
Wir gehen zurück und schauen,
wann wir den zum ersten Mal fingen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Zwölf Flugstunden entfernt ist das
neue Jahr gerade mal einen Tag alt.
Wer kann, bleibt zu Hause, denn
in Zürich bläst ein eisiger Wind.
Doch einige Mutige
beeindruckt das nicht.
Der Tauchclub Zürichsee trifft sich
zum alljährlichen Neujahrsanlass.
Was fehlt noch?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Becher und so.
- Braucht's noch etwas?
Becher.
Ja, Becher.
Der Wind bläst sie sicher weg.
Tauchclubpräsident Agi Uhr und seine
Tochter Tanja sind seit Stunden wach
und haben Bouillon
und Glühwein für alle zubereitet.
Gibt es noch Hotdogs?
Willst du gleich einen?
Oder nachher?
Wir machen
den ersten Tauchgang des Jahres.
Das beginnt natürlich im neuen Jahr.
Der 1. Januar geht nicht gut, da ist
noch niemand wieder ganz nüchtern.
Deshalb machen wir ihn
jetzt regelmässig am 2. Januar -
seit 22 Jahren,
habe ich im Jahresbericht gesehen.
Das Wasser der Limmat beim Zürcher
Bauschänzli misst gerade mal 4 °C.
Die Taucher springen bei der Mole
rein, tauchen ums Bauschänzli rum
und kommen hier wieder raus. Es hat
keine andere Ausstiegmöglichkeit.
Wir müssen die Leiter selber setzen.
Die leidenschaftlichen Hobbytaucher
haben schon so Einiges
aus der Limmat gefischt -
vom Gebiss bis zum Tresor.
Was hast du schon gefunden?
Ein Goldkettchen, eine Zwanziger-
note, die im Wasser schwamm.
Und was wir gesehen,
aber nicht raufgeholt haben,
sind Einkaufswagen, dort vorne mal
Fahrräder. - Die waren zu schwer?
Ja, das tun wir uns
auf unserem Tauchgang nicht an.
Das holen wir eher an einer unserer
Limmat-Säuberungsaktionen rauf.
Bestens, Agi. - Gut tauch!
- Viel Spass.
Kommt etwas näher,
damit ich nicht so schreien muss.
Ich möchte alle herzlich
beim Tauchclub Zürichsee begrüssen
zum Neujahrstauchen,
das wir jedes Jahr veranstalten.
Der Einstieg ist auf dieser Rampe.
Hier könnt ihr rein, abtauchen,
in der Mitte des Sees durch.
Es gab eine Neuauflage: Wir dürfen
nicht mehr auf die andere Seite.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
wie gut ihr im Kompasstauchen seid.
* Lachen *
Es geht nicht darum, das Bauschänzli
von Unrat zu befreien.
Vielmehr nimmt jeder
einen bis zwei Gegenstände raus -
es kann auch ein Fahrrad sein.
* Lachen *
Nehmt es raus,
wir platzieren es dann oben.
Es ist immer interessant,
was da alles zum Vorschein kommt.
Gut, dann gut tauch!
Offiziell wünschen sich die Taucher
allerdings etwas Existenzielleres:
Gut Luft!
Dass man immer genügend Luft hat
unter Wasser.
Das ist eigentlich
der einzige Spruch: gut Luft!
Agi und Tochter Tanja
vergessen die Kälte
und sind gespannt,
was sie unter Wasser erwartet.
Gut?
Ja.
In der indonesischen Tauchregion
Raja Ampat
sind die Kinder
voller Eifer bei der Sache.
Sie reinigen den Strand vom Abfall,
den die Strömung angeschwemmt hat.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Machen wir hier noch sauber
und bringen alles dort rüber.
Jetzt haben wir doch vermutlich
innerhalb 15-20 Min.
fünf grosse Säcke gefüllt.
Selbst die Strände, die von Weitem
sauber aussehen, sind voller Abfall.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Was ist das Problem
mit diesem Abfall?
Die Kügelchen
bleiben im Hals stecken.
Denn im Wasser sieht
das aus wie? - (Alle) Plankton.
Plankton. Und der Manta?
- Isst es.
Was passiert?
- Er stirbt.
Okay, hier wirft jemand
ein Papiertaschentuch ins Meer.
Wie lange dauert es,
bis es abgebaut ist?
Einen Monat.
- Nur einen Monat.
Wie lange dauert es bei einer
Plastiktüte? - (Alle) 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre. Was frisst die Schildkröte
im Buch? - Plastik.
Und was dachte sie, dass sie frisst?
- Eine Qualle. - Eine Qualle.
Schildkröten fressen Plastik.
Wale, Delfine, Mantas.
Alle unsere Freunde im Meer
können daran sterben.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass immer mehr hängen bleibt.
Wenn sie im Meer Abfall sehen,
holen sie ihn raus.
Sie sagen oft von sich aus:
"Dort sieht es nicht schön aus."
"Komm, wir räumen auf."
Oder wenn sie schnorcheln, sammeln
sie von sich aus den Abfall auf.
Die Kinder machen sicherlich
sehr erfreuliche Fortschritte.
Es ist ein Anfang.
Aber das riesige Abfallproblem
können die Kinder nicht lösen.
Wir suchen aus dem Abfall alles
raus, das wir verbrennen können.
Z.B. leichtes Plastik. Dafür gibt es
leider keine bessere Lösung.
Man muss ihn verbrennen.
Sonst müsste man ihn mit dem
Flugzeug nach Singapur schicken,
was auch nicht sinnvoll ist.
Wir passen auf, dass die Kinder
nicht den Rauch einatmen,
da Rauch von Plastikabfall
sehr gefährlich ist.
Nur eine professionelle
Abfallentsorgung
kann
die Umwelt nachhaltig schützen.
Jonas hat eine Vision:
Das Ziel wäre, dass es eines Tages
eine richtige Stelle für Abfall
in Wasai,
dem Hauptort von Raja Ampat, gibt.
Man müsste
ein grösseres Boot organisieren,
das z.B. zweimal pro Monat
bei jedem Dorf vorbeifährt.
Es fährt in Raja Ampat rum,
sammelt den ganzen Abfall ein
und bringt diesen nach Wasai.
Dort müsste der Abfall unter kor-
rekten Bedingungen verbrannt werden.
Es wäre toll, wenn man
in den nächsten ein bis zwei Jahren
so etwas realisieren könnte.
Das wäre genial -
und für Raja Ampat extrem wichtig.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Eindringliche Töne *
Auch am Grund der Limmat hinterlässt
die moderne Zivilisation ihre Spuren.
Agi und Tanja folgen ihnen.
* Beklemmende Töne *
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf den Seychellen ist Ornella Wei-
deli auf der Forschungsinsel D'Arros
schon früh auf den Beinen.
Hier ist der Pottwal, der vor
einigen Monaten angeschwemmt wurde.
Wir wissen nicht, weshalb er starb.
Als wir ihn fanden, waren schon
Tigerhaie dabei, ihn zu fressen.
Leider ist er
vom Vermodern etwas schwarz.
Aber er wird bald geputzt,
dann sieht er wieder schöner aus.
Ornella will die Daten
der gestrigen Exkursion auswerten.
Das Verhalten von Junghaien
interessiert sie so sehr,
dass sie es zum Thema
ihrer Doktorarbeit gemacht hat.
Gestern haben wir
Haie Nr. 700, 701 und 702 gefangen.
702.
Okay, der wurde
bereits einmal gefangen -
und zwar am 5. Oktober 2017.
Es ist noch nicht sehr lange her,
ein halbes Jahr.
In der Zone B zur Zone A.
Das sind zwischen 500 und 1'000 m.
Sie gehen nicht weit.
Und dann kann ich schauen,
wie viel er gewachsen ist.
4,2 cm gewachsen.
Er hat aber abgenommen.
Z.T. haben wir Neugeborene,
die richtig dick sind.
Die sind voll.
Beim ersten Mal fragten wir uns,
weshalb sie so voll sind.
Es ist ihre Leber,
die sehr, sehr gross ist,
die vollgestopft ist
mit Fettreserven der Mutter.
Jetzt ist ein halbes Jahr vorbei,
er hat die Energie der Leber
in seinen Körper aufgenommen,
ist aber gleichzeitig gewachsen.
Wir wissen: Es geht ihm gut.
Es ist typisch,
dass der Umfang zurückgeht.
Ich gebe noch die anderen drei ein,
die wir gestern gefangen haben.
An der Limmat
kann der Tauchclub Zürichsee
allerlei Trophäen an Land ziehen.
Gegenstände,
die mit oder ohne Absicht
auf dem Grund der Limmat landeten.
Ha! Laptop.
Achtung! Den Humpen habe ich nicht.
- Nein.
Schau, sie haben auch ein Fahrrad.
Unten.
- Kriegst du es hier hoch?
Es fährt noch. - Hinten hat es noch
Luft. Du könntest rumfahren.
Frauenhandtaschen
sind unergründlich tief.
Ein Brillenetui, ID.
So kann man es zuordnen,
wenn wir eine ID haben.
Das Handy ist
natürlich auch nicht mehr so ...
Kopfhörer
und diverser kleiner Krimskrams.
Auto- und Hausschlüssel
wird sie auch suchen.
In solchen Fällen
informieren die Taucher die Polizei.
Gegenstände, die niemandem gehören,
werden entsorgt.
Schau mal, alles!
Laptop, Telefon, Natel, Humpen.
Messer.
Sonnenbrille.
Irgendwo habe ich noch ein Handy.
- Da hinten.
iPhone.
Samsung.
Ja.
Es ist traurig, dass solche Ware
hier reingeschmissen wird.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Gerade ein Laptop.
Das ist der zweite oder dritte,
den wir in den letzten Jahren
rausgeholt haben.
Ein iPhone kann mal jemandem -
nicht direkt aus der Hand fallen -,
aber wenn er so macht, fliegt es
weg. - Pass mit dem Messer auf!
Es ist traurig,
dass man alles reinschmeisst.
Aha! Portemonnaie.
Ohne Geld drin.
Dann eine Uhr.
Mit Schloss.
Was ist die letzte Vignette?
* Fliessende,
schnelle Gitarrenklänge *
In der bekannten Tauchregion
von Raja Ampat
ist die Marineartenvielfalt
überwältigend.
1'400 Fischarten gibt es hier.
Und über 500 Korallenarten.
Jonas Müller will, dass diese
prächtige Natur erhalten bleibt.
Doch die Insel Arborek
ist innert weniger Jahre
zu einem Touristenmagneten geworden.
Das hinterlässt Spuren.
In der Indonesierin Maya
hat Jonas eine Verbündete
für sein Engagement für die Umwelt
gefunden.
Erinnerst du dich? Dieser Anlegesteg
war unter Tauchern der berühmteste.
Ja. Und überall gab es Fisch-
schwärme. Die sind verschwunden.
Und all die schönen Korallen,
alle weg.
Und schau mal diese Wellen,
die grossen Boote.
Und all die neuen Gebäude.
Das ist Wahnsinn!
Es wird
all die schönen Korallen zerstören.
* Jonas spricht indonesisch. *
Jonas macht seinem Ärger Luft.
Guides und Touristen
ermahnt er zu mehr Sorgsamkeit.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Das Parkverbot für die Schiffe
bleibt unbeachtet.
Das ist
der Anfang des Massentourismus.
so gut wie das Ende von Arborek.
Wir sahen, dass sie Fische füttern.
Das macht das Ökosystem kaputt.
Die meisten - man sieht es dort
vorne - stehen auf die Korallen.
Sie denken, es seien Steine.
Es sind aber Korallen.
Mein Vorschlag war einmal, auf
dem Steg einen Posten aufzubauen,
der kontrolliert,
welche Boote kommen,
und überprüft, ob sie
die Eintrittsgebühr bezahlt haben.
Es muss am Steg jemand aufpassen,
dass niemand auf die Korallen steht.
Die Boote dürfen nicht
wie zurzeit an den Steg knallen.
Es müsste limitiert
werden auf z.B. max. zwei Boote
und eine bestimmte Anzahl
Schnorchler.
Sobald sie gehen,
kommt ein anderes Boot.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Jonas und seine Kollegin Maya
wollen ein Zeichen setzen
und eine Nichtregierungsorganisation
mit Einheimischen gründen.
Sie soll helfen,
die Natur zu schützen.
Das Gute daran wäre:
Wir könnten wegen genau solcher
Probleme wie der Anlegestelle
zur lokalen Aufsichtsbehörde gehen
und hätten so
eine gesetzliche Basis.
Ja, dann sind es
nicht nur wir als Privatpersonen.
Nur, wenn Jonas
auch Einheimische überzeugen kann,
in der Organisation mitzuarbeiten,
können sie gemeinsam die Folgen
des Massentourismus bekämpfen.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Da, wo es besonders kalt ist,
am Polarkreis
zwischen Island und Grönland,
wird es ihm warm ums Herz.
Ich freue mich riesig.
Ich glaube, es ist ziemlich kalt.
Ich bin gespannt
und ein bisschen nervös.
* Leise, ruhige Klänge *
Robert Hansen reist aus Zürich an.
Seine Leidenschaft gilt dem Filmen,
Fotografieren und Eistauchen.
Dafür nehmen der Multimediajournalist
und seine Frau Renée
Einiges auf sich.
Es ist unglaublich,
was es dazu an Ausrüstung braucht.
Ich alleine habe 66 kg.
Plus noch mal 23.
Dann sind es 86.
Kann ich noch Kopfrechnen?
Zu zweit haben wir ca. 100 kg.
Das würde vom Tragen her alles
gehen, aber der Heli war so teuer.
Da kostet ein Gepäckstück mehr
als der Passagier.
Robert Hansen ist in Grönland.
In der grössten Stadt
an der Ostküste: Tasiilaq.
Gerade mal 2'000 Menschen leben hier.
Mit Dänemark fühlte ich mich
immer sehr verbunden.
Grönland war ein Kindheitstraum.
Von meinem Vater hatte ich Bücher,
die ich immer wieder anschaute.
Das arktische Leben hier oben
hat mich immer sehr fasziniert.
Es brauchte fast 50 Jahre, bis ich
das tatsächlich umsetzen durfte.
Tasiilaq bedeutet:
der Ort mit einem See.
Die Menschen hier leben
von der Fischerei und dem Tourismus.
Besonders angetan
hat es Robert der Kong-Oscar-Hafen.
Eine grandiose Kulisse, ich bin
jedes Mal einfach überwältigt.
Mir sagte mal jemand, man solle nie
den schönsten Ort verraten,
den man kennt,
sondern nur den zweitschönsten.
Das ist wirklich
einer der schönsten, die ich kenne.
Das widerspricht dem ein bisschen.
Ja, es ist ambivalent, klar.
Es gibt beide Seiten.
Man zeigt etwas Schönes, andere
werden motiviert, hierherzukommen.
Das Gute ist, es können gar nicht
so viele Leute kommen,
weil die Infrastruktur nicht
wahnsinnig gross ist.
Man muss zu Hause bleiben,
wenn man gar nichts mehr
auf der Welt anschauen will,
weil schlussendlich
alles einen Fussabdruck hinterlässt.
Wir in Westeuropa
werden immer auf der Seite stehen,
wo es mehr kaputt macht als fördert,
das ist völlig klar.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Seychellen sind seit Langem
ein beliebtes Ferienziel.
Ein Teil der Region
steht bereits unter Schutz.
Ornella Weideli kommt
seit vier Jahren regelmässig hierher.
Jetzt taucht sie mit ihren Kollegen
ab, um die Wasserwelt zu inspizieren.
Wir gehen zu Tippers,
einem wunderschönen Tauchplatz
am Riffrand des Saint-Joseph-Atolls.
Sehr bekannt für Schildkröten
und Schwarzspitzen-Riffhaie.
Ryan Daly ist der lokale
wissenschaftliche Leiter
der Schweizer Stiftung Save Our Seas.
Er und Michael Scholl, der Direktor
der Stiftung, wollen erreichen,
dass auch die Region um D'Arros
unter Schutz gestellt wird.
* Ruhige Klänge
und Zischen des Atems *
Schon bald
zeigen sich verschiedene Haiarten.
Geschützte Orte wie diese Höhle
werden von Glasfischen bewohnt.
Der grosse Fledermausfisch
kennt keine Scheu.
Die Unterwassergäste werden beäugt.
Auch von einem Zackenbarsch.
Grüne Meeresschildkröten sind hier
seit über 20 Jahren geschützt
und sind seither verbreitet.
Ryan wird von einem
Riesen-Drückerfisch attackiert,
der sein Revier verteidigt.
Er kann schmerzhaft zubeissen.
Ah, das war herrlich!
Die Korallen hier waren wahnsinnig
schön, aber leider ...
Den Unterschied sieht man ziemlich
gut. - Ja, ja, sehr gut, leider.
Es hat sich extrem verändert.
Es ist schlimm.
Wann passierte
das mit der Korallenbleiche? 2016?
Die Ursache für Korallenbleiche
liegt bei der globalen Erwärmung.
Das erste Mal
beobachteten wir das 1998.
Es war eine Folge von Klimawandel
und globaler Erwärmung.
Es wird noch häufig auftreten, aus-
ser wir ändern unseren Lebensstil.
Aber die Haie sind immer noch da.
Ja, es waren ca. sechs.
- Gut sechs, ja.
Auch die Attacke des Drückerfischs
ist ein Thema.
Es war lustig,
du wurdest von ihm angegriffen
und hinter dir waren zwei Haie,
die niemand beachtete.
Der Riesen-Drückerfisch
hat mich in die Flosse gebissen.
Er hat sein Nest verteidigt
und duldet keine Eindringlinge.
Das hat so lustig ausgesehen!
Es war nett, dass du in meine Nähe
kamst in der Hoffnung,
dass er mich wählt:
"Nimm doch den, da ist mehr dran."
Zurück in Tasiilaq.
Der Hafen
ist nicht sehr bewegt im Moment.
Hier sind
relativ viele Segelschiffe.
Wir sahen im Sommer auch schon Boote
aus der Schweiz, die anlandeten.
Jetzt ist alles zugefroren.
Es dauert einige Monate,
bis das erste Versorgungsschiff
aus Dänemark kommt.
D.h., frische Lebensmittel
gibt es erst dann wieder.
9.95 Kronen.
Nicht pro Kilo, sondern pro Apfel.
1.70 Fr. für einen Apfel.
Das ist ein stolzer Preis.
Spaghetti Napoli, allerdings sehen
diese Würste etwas merkwürdig aus.
Ja.
Es sind natürlich häufig Konserven.
Die halten mehrere Jahre.
In der nächsten Folge muss sich Ro-
bert Hansen das Eistauchen verdienen.
Wir sind jetzt seit 3 Std. dran
und haben noch kein schlaues Loch.
In Indonesien bekommt Jonas Müller
Besuch von seinen Eltern aus Glarus.
Dass man die Schönheit
miteinander teilen kann, ist super!
Und Ornella Weideli taucht ein in
die zauberhafte Welt der Mantarochen.